[Music]  Scott Disick packs on the PDA with  Sophia Ricci for her big night on  Wednesday more Disick stepped out to  support Sophia at the Art Basel kick-off  party celebrating her new jaw recover at  the confidante Hotel in Miami the 19  year old model stole the spotlight  sporting a sexy LBD with a major slit  but all eyes were on Scott and Sophia  cozying up to each other inside the bash  and eye witness tells et the two were  seen chatting and kissing throughout the  evening Scott and Sophia appeared to be  going strong  before the party the pair reunited on  the beach for a relaxing day in the Sun  Sophia sizzled in a red hot bikini and  daisy dukes  while scott wore his comfy beach wear a  white shirt plaid shorts and his custom  Lord Disick embroidered loafers  [Music]